welcome to a new 15-minute game against
maxi moose Maximus from Finland let's
see what we are right he knows that I'm
recording yes I'm recording
he's saying oh no ok let's let's just
play a game it's supposed to be fun
right he's playing the English defense
hmm let's see I don't want to place a
complicated stuff against that maybe
something something solid we should be
seven or Bishop before I'm going to play
I'm going to play this a very solid
fashion
it was Bishop before I play 92 okay yeah
this is also possible of course now my
intention was to play Knight to f4 yeah
let's let's go there
this Knight on f4 has some some points
it makes it difficult for black to play
the D pawn at any point of course in six
is hanging and a young came I don't
really want the telephone here and this
thing regarding the D pawn is also
influencing the knight IAM and how does
the knight develop probably needs to go
to a six then okay I'm just just
continue normally g2 is also covered
additional side effect of this night
okay now this is not a mainline or
anything
putting the night on f4 but okay let's
see what evolves he can of course try to
prepare something like d6 with queenie 7
and then d6 yeah many possibilities he
can also the simple solution here would
be to just take on c3 and play Knight e4
get rid of two pairs of minor pieces
this should ease blacks task somewhat
maybe something that I would consider
also of course Queen is seven yeah this
is this is possible sure as mentioned
it's not so easy now to to play the 6 mm
I could go Bishop f3 but okay maybe not
immediately
night a-sixes son very often only useful
if you manage if you somehow get nc5 fc5
and then get the night begin to play
otherwise it does not do much on 86 I
don't like it too much
night a6 really think him may be trading
on c3 and 94 on Queenie 7 was Batum
trying to play d6 97 at at a later stage
I mean like it's not in an immediate
trouble here
I'm not suggestion suggesting that the
term don't like the night only six very
much what is my next move him not eat
him yeah okay now I need to react
somehow to c5 I was thinking I could
just do a three maybe two to force him
to commit but there are other there are
other ways to play I was also thinking
about night to b5 going going towards d6
but isn't this good if I if I keep the
dark squared Bishop iam my ideas that
now if he goes 94 which pretty much
looks like the only logical continuation
otherwise I keep the keep the bishop
easily let's say any move I go b3 Bishop
b2 on some that 94 it's not securing
this Bishop hmm yeah I thought I thought
really that b3 is good now and that's
also before I need to consider that as
well
yeah the question is what about what
about this 65 quickly hmm okay let's
let's do that first I want to have P
should be 2 or 94 but he is probably
going to play d6 anyway the question is
what to do after d6 maybe maybe Bishop
f3 okay yeah this is easy this I wanted
to do that anyway yeah but it's this
really working well together with 94 so
defy a few rd v e5 Knight is 6 and then
f3 and f4 probably okay no need to waste
time on that
yeah and the problem is
look at this bishop this is just Oh he's
not playing e5 interesting
hmm
okay very unexpected
but not a bad move probably preparing e5
okay this means I have I need to take it
and on 96 probably 95 m
yeah I have this absolutely amazing
diagonal here for the bishop of course
he's got on b7 a bishops law but I can
if everything else fails block it with
f3 and she cannot do the same he has got
the F pawn moved well wait f3
whereas the night going and three now
tactical news 95 h 4 wins apiece and
Knight f6 looks like it's not really on
I can take with the 96 and that's it
yeah I should have thought a bit longer
maybe it's 15 minutes yes I can invest a
moment but I don't really see anything
no I don't see a good reply
yeah night for 2g via this is of course
it looks terrible but what should he do
okay yeah Jain this is this is very very
tough now with the long diagonal looming
the check and go into H form probably
yeah okay yeah hmm not much I can do
about it I would have preferred not to
exchange Queens because my king is the
safer saver one but not much I can do
about it
okay rook t1 is logical and Europe t2 is
something I need to prevent some rock t1
is an easy move to play
and I could could play something like
Queen h4 keeping the Queen's on that way
but okay it's already a position where I
also have an extra on an extra pawn so I
don't need to to have to were to rush
things here okay King moves to do what
rope g8 maybe okay I just I just stop
don't don't mind that and in any endgame
I have two bishops and the pawn so I can
I can just trade pieces check
so now with rocks off if he does not
trade I can try to pressurize them yeah
I thought if for him maybe there's
something better
yeah go okay f4 is some it's um it's
giving up the Foursquare I don't like
that so much okay if I go King f2 and
hit playing f4 take Knight takes more
might be might be somewhat tricky don't
really like that
yeah Bishop c1 is a very passive looking
move but it's really not bad right
it just covers it just does what needs
to be done covering this pawn and I can
I can play Bishop c2 soon okay
but I cannot activate the Queen if you
would would be able to play somehow
Queen into my camp Queen g6 to be one or
so but it's it's simply not on okay this
is attacking nothing so I can go here or
not Queen G for this f5 Queen g5 queen
is six that's not so great or name
somehow to how to how to win the snow it
cannot really activate the Queen don't
don't really see how but now now it's
also a force not hanging anymore so
maybe just Bishop b2
mm you can play night at 5:00 now yeah
but I have I have Queen here also night
III does Queen d7 check
yeah it's no move really yeah
that's funky I take when you won
checkmate
so just just trade that's that's much
easier
no activate activate the pieces maybe
jump ok that's it's good enough really
that's good enough
King F to us maybe a bit more precise
because 96 now I cannot play g3 and I
really want to play g3 so I must go back
again but okay it just not really it
does not really hurt hurt my course I
can play King F too soon maybe even then
g4 f5 and push the pawns forward
yeah this was really a matter of this
blunder Queen f7 before that I mean I
approve I would prefer white but because
of the bishops but it's not not the end
of the world the only thing I really
shouldn't do is take on g6 getting two
opposite colored bishops it's really not
advisable anymore yeah yeah the best way
here is I think g4 and f5 so that
potentially my bishop on c1 can enter my
f4 yeah I can do that now right yeah if
he does not trade I play f5 and King g3
trapping the yep
King g3 will win the knight next move it
does not have any square sides yeah it
was really just this move I mean other
other than that he played it fine let's
let's see here briefly Queen f7 really I
mean he needs to go some melts or the
computer is already very pessimistic
about black me I didn't think it was so
terrible Queen g5 is the the computer
suggestion yeah this is of course better
than Queen f7
yeah
not easy to say what I should do here
many ideas f3 is the possible movie
something like that is an interesting
way to go and it's always the bishop's I
mean it was really much much easier to
instead of Queen e7 go here and I would
have played Bishop you want to preserve
it but this is just far less comfortable
then this b3 business where I can just
really Park it nicely on v2 yeah it was
a bit a bit tricky I think really the
easiest way to play as I mentioned
around here to just take it and play
here get this get this get this Bishop
but probably play something like that
and here black has some decent chances
to to equalize of course with two pairs
of minor pieces exchanged this shouldn't
be shouldn't be so bad yeah here this is
really complicated that you can the
beauty of this type of opening for black
is the flexibility was you can play with
the c5 with d6 at some point you have
not committed the center early so I have
many options but him I think he really
should do that too to make me play
Bishop e1 and then go from there the
computer has a crazy suggestion your g5
this is are just utterly crazy
yeah just crazy this is what the
computer wants to do it can never be
good really it gives white one pawn
advantage but says it's the best line
cannot really cannot
believe that maybe just Queenie seven or
something and then I go here and then I
go from there I'm not sure I can I can
go here but this is not as convincing as
having the bishop on me - yeah an
interesting game I hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching